SUDHIR HASBE: Welcome, everyone,
to the Smart Analytics Roadmap
session.
I'm Sudhir Hasbe.
I'm the Director of Product
for Smart Analytics at Google
Cloud.
Data across
organizations is growing.
And then organizations need a
very strong analytics platform
to leverage this
data, create insights,
and make real-time decisions
on top of this data.
At Google Cloud, we
are a data company.
We basically collect
massive amounts of data.
We leverage our machine
learning and AI capabilities
to generate insights from
them and power our products.
We have more than
nine products--
we have nine products that have
more than a billion users that
use it every day.
At Google Cloud,
we have also seen
convergence of a lot of
these technology trends.
We've seen organizations
are breaking down
data silos between data
lakes and data warehouses.
As organizations
are moving to cloud,
they want to be
able to interoperate
between all of these data
assets that have been created.
Second, we have
seen organizations
focused a lot more on
real-time decision-making.
And lot of processes
historically
have been built for
batch processing.
And this transition to
real-time processing
is requiring organizations
to think about,
how do you go ahead and build
consolidated solutions that
can run on both real time
as well as batch data?
And then, finally, analytics
and AI, merging these concepts,
data scientists are
spending 80% in some studies
on data preparation.
And analysts are trying to go
in and do predictive analytics
on top of data that they have.
And convergence of
these different users
within organizations, use cases
is also becoming a norm now.
So at Google Cloud, our vision
is to go ahead and provide you
with an enterprise-class
data platform that
is proven to be dependable.
We at Google actually
have services
that are built for scale,
built for availability.
So we want to bring
that same kind of record
to our data platform.
The other thing is we believe in
open and flexible capabilities.
We are also leveraging some of
the intelligence capabilities
with AI/ML, embedding
it within our products.
So we want to provide you with
this end-to-end Smart Analytics
platform that allows you to go
ahead and get more value out
of your data.
So what does the
platform entail?
You can go in and collect
massive amounts of events
in real time or in
batch with the platform.
Organizations like Spotify are
collecting events every time
you play a song.
The event gets collected
across the globe using Pub/Sub.
They process the data
through Dataflow,
which is a streaming
service that
allows you to go ahead and
do stream processing as well
as batch processing.
You could also use
Dataproc, which
is a managed Hadoop
and Spark environment
with similar kind of data sets.
And then you can use BigQuery
for large-scale analysis.
In addition to that, we have
launched migration service
that allows you
to easily migrate
from your traditional data
warehouses to BigQuery.
We launched Data Fusion.
It's a data integration service.
Visually, you can create
data pipelines end to end
and then go ahead
and deploy it on GCP.
We went GA end of last year.
And we have seen
tremendous interest
in this from customers
across the globe.
Dataprep is a data
wrangling service.
It's a partnership
with Trifacta.
It allows you to go ahead and do
zero-code data wrangling, data
preparation.
Now, we are also going to
have a couple of new SKUs
that are being launched
for Dataprep as we
go into this year.
The other thing is also--
now, from a storage
perspective, you
can leverage
BigQuery or Bigtable.
Lot of organizations
use Bigtable
as their backbone for
high-throughput data sets,
like when you need it for your
e-commerce website and all.
And organizations use BigQuery
for large-scale analytical data
sets.
It's a analytical store.
And then you can use BigQuery
for analysis with SQL.
It has various different
capabilities in SQL.
And then things like
BI Engine, which
is our in-memory technology,
embedded machine learning.
So you can create
machine learning models
with just a couple
of lines of SQL.
And then you can also
use Spark with Dataproc.
A lot of organizations
like using
Spark ML for machine
learning models and all.
You can do that with Dataproc.
And then, finally, to
activate, to take actions
on top of your data,
you can use Looker.
Looker is a great
addition to our platform.
We'll talk more about that
later in the presentation.
Connected Sheets-- you can
now leverage Connected Sheets,
like Google Sheets, to
leverage the power of BigQuery
on the back end.
You can take a
petabyte-scale data set
and just start analyzing
it with Connected Sheets.
And then on top of
that, we launched Data
Catalog earlier in the year.
It allows you to go in and
get better data, understanding
of your environment.
You can search for any
data set that you have,
put some policies
on top of that data.
And then Composer, which is
our workflow orchestration
capability, which
has managed Airflow,
allows you to bring all of
these services together.
So overall, if you look at
the platform, you can collect,
you can process the data.
You can store it in various
different platform solutions
that we have for
different use cases.
You can analyze it at
scale, and then you
can activate on top of that
data the different kind
of activations.
One of the other things we
were talking about earlier
is this interoperability.
So at Google Cloud, one of
our key value propositions
is to go ahead and have this
completely interoperable
environment, where you can have
your data in a data warehouse
or in data lake or
in databases, and you
can use the same BigQuery engine
to go ahead and run queries
across all of them,
even Google Sheets.
Then on the other side,
if you store your data
in BigQuery, which is a
highly analytical store,
you can then use any
of the other engines,
including-- like, you can
use the BigQuery engine,
but you can also use Spark
engine with Dataproc.
You can use Beam with Dataflow.
You can use Cloud AI.
So all of these different
engines, like AutoML and all,
they seamlessly work
on Cloud or BigQuery.
So this interoperability is one
of the key value propositions
that we are focused on.
We have added a lot of
capabilities in the last year
or so.
And then we continue
to improve it as we go.
We have seen tremendous
growth across the globe.
Every industry, every
region, organizations
like from Home Depot
to AirAsia, HSBC, UPS--
like, you will see different
kind of organizations.
Some of them like cloud native
startups, to Twitters and all,
and to traditional
enterprise organizations
using the platform.
Also today, as I talk
through the roadmap,
I want to take you through four
different kinds of use cases
that organizations
use, or scenarios.
One is with modernizing your
data analytics with BigQuery,
data lakes for
Dataproc and Composer,
more responsive businesses
with Dataflow and Pub/Sub,
and then finally,
Enterprise BI with Looker.
Let's talk about BigQuery.
BigQuery is highly
scalable cloud data
warehousing solution.
We have customers that have
few terabytes to hundreds
of petabytes within BigQuery.
It's completely serverless.
You bring data in, load
it, and start query.
You don't have to worry
about machines and operations
and manageability or
anything like that.
It allows you to do
real-time streaming.
We have customers that are
ingesting tens of millions
of events every day--
sorry, tens of millions
of events every second
into BigQuery.
We have embedded
machine learning.
And then we also enable
insights for everyone
within organization.
With investments like
Connected Sheets,
now data and insights is
accessible to everyone.
One of the other innovations
that we have worked on
is around the pricing.
So BigQuery is 10 years
old in June this year.
We became 10 years.
We pioneered the pricing
model of pay per query.
But over a period of
time, organizations
have asked for
different options.
So we launched BigQuery
flat rate, which
is subscription
pricing every month,
fixed price, so that
you can go ahead
and leverage BigQuery with
a consistent price point.
We also had a lot
of customers ask us
for this burst per second,
per minute billing so
that they can bring
workloads that are bursty.
Monday morning, ETL
jobs have to run.
Or you have Black Friday,
even, that happens in the US.
So all of these different
kinds of use cases
needed this burst capability.
The beauty of three pricing
models with BigQuery
is you can actually
interchange them.
You can basically
use all three of them
in a mix-and-match fashion
within your organization
and go ahead and
leverage each one of them
for different
kinds of use cases.
So you can easily
mix and match these.
Let's talk about
BigQuery roadmap.
I want to highlight a
few of the key things.
But there is another session.
At the bottom of the screen, you
will see these recommendations
I have for different sessions
that give you a deep dive
into the specific areas.
But let's talk about the BI
Engine and materialized views,
always fast, always fresh,
BigQuery ML, Data QnA,
in Omni today.
Always fast, always
fresh-- this is
our theme around collecting
large-scale events
in real time.
We have rebuilt our
whole storage engine
to be streaming first.
Along with that, we
have materialized
views, where what
users can do is
they can take this data
that's streaming, coming in
or any batch of
data that comes in.
You can partition
and cluster it so
that the queries become faster.
But with materialized
views, you can actually
preaggregate and keep the
data sets ready for the use
case that needs low latency.
One of the best things
about materialized views
is, as the underneath data
changes, we automatically
update your materialized view.
You do not have to
worry about, like,
running scheduled jobs or not.
We will automatically
materialize it.
Second thing we do is, if
a query is written after--
if you have an old query that
doesn't use materialized view,
but you've created
this materialized view,
internally, our query engine
will read out the queries
to go through materialized view.
So that's a really
good capability
so you don't have to
worry about changing
all your queries at all.
And finally,
BigQuery BI Engine--
so BI Engine allows you to
have this in-memory caching
layer on top of
BigQuery that gives you
subsecond latency response
times on your BI use cases.
Today, it only works
with Data Studio.
But later in the
year, we will make
it available through
Double SQL, which
is our internal name
for our SQL capability.
So any query coming
to BigQuery will
be able to leverage BI Engine.
So this will be available
through on the BI tools, JDBC
drivers, as well as the
queries that you fire.
It will give you really fast
response times on top of that.
And we will also support
some of the star schemas
for BI Engine use cases.
Another thing is nothing
changes on your side.
Write the same query.
We will automatically fall
down to whichever layer has
the most cache results for you.
So if it's BI Engine in-memory
caching, we'll use that.
If not, we'll fall
to materialized view.
If not, to partition
and cluster.
Let's switch gears,
talk about BigQuery ML.
BigQuery ML is our embedded
machine learning capability.
It allows you to write
two lines of code
to create machine
learning models
and then get predictions
with similar kind of tool.
There are two lines of code.
So we launched this a
year and a half back.
And then since
then, we have been
adding all these
different types of models.
We have seen tremendous
interest in k-means clustering.
We've made matrix
recommendations,
or recommendations for
matrix factorization.
We have customers who have taken
their historical user data,
gone ahead and create clusters
based on what type of users
are there.
And then our two product
recommendations to them
were using matrix factorization.
In recent times, we've also
added new capabilities,
where now you can connect
to Cloud AI services
and their capabilities,
like AutoML Tables.
Now, BigQuery ML,
with two lines of SQL,
you can leverage AutoML.
And you can use
XGBoost from there.
DNN models with it.
So we are basically making it--
all the different
Cloud AI capabilities
more accessible through SQL
for our BigQuery and our data
analyst community.
We also have the
time-series forecasting.
But the most important
thing that we have added
is this interoperability
with TensorFlow.
Now you can take the model
that you created in BigQuery,
export it into
TensorFlow, and then
load it into your
serving platform
and make it more accessible
in the real-time world.
The other theme we have had is
this democratizing insights.
With Connected Sheets, you can
take a petabyte-scale table
and then have a great
visualization, great analysis
with Connected Sheets
or GSuite Sheets.
With Data QnA, now you
can use natural language
to get your questions answered.
So it's basically, you just ask
the question, get an answer.
This is going to free up a lot
of time for BI teams, right?
You don't have to now create
a custom dashboard order
report for every
question that comes up.
You can just ask it.
The main thing that
we're focused on
is making this available through
various different experiences.
We do realize organizations
want different experiences
with natural language.
In many cases, it's all
available through an API.
So organizations can build
their own custom experiences.
We will make it available
through Google Sheets.
We will have some chat bots,
dialog flow integration.
So all of these
different integrations
are planned to be coming.
It's all built on an internal
technology called Analyza.
There's a great paper on
it if you're interested.
But this is same
technology that also
powers Google Assistant and
various different services
that we have internally.
It allows us to go ahead and
get question parsing, intent
identification, and
entity matching, all
done automatically using
the same technology.
And then the SQL and
how we map to BigQuery
is where we are
innovating right now.
So great new capability
if you're interested.
Now, you should reach out to
us so that we can give you
early access and all.
The other big area--
every organization is in
multicloud environment now.
If not, they will be
in sometime to come.
Few years back, there is always
the question-- which cloud,
why cloud, and all of that.
Now I talk to customers
across the globe.
Most of the questions
that they ask
is, what are the key
capabilities in which cloud?
And how do I leverage
them for their use cases?
So BigQuery Omni is
our ability to take
some of our core
capabilities, the BigQuery,
and extend them into
other cloud environments.
So while you will get
the same experience,
you'd still go to
the BigQuery UI.
You still write the
similar queries.
You're just now accessing
data on different clouds.
So that's one main thing.
And then finally, we're
leveraging Anthos internally
so that the management of
the machines and all of that
is not your problem.
We'll just do that
behind the scenes.
The way to think
about this is, we
are announcing the
availability on Azure
in the early alpha
phases, where, really, you
can reach out to us, and you can
start testing and validations
and stuff like that.
We will make it available to
organizations and form a beta
and all later in
the year and all
But the way to think about it
is, it's just another region.
So you would have the same
control plane, same query
experience in BigQuery.
But today, you can
connect to US and EU
multiregion or one of
the regional deployments
of BigQuery data sets.
And now the data in S3 just
becomes another data set
for you to go ahead and query.
We will take our Compute
Engine and run it in AWS
so you don't pay any egress
charges back and forth
within that.
The only time egress
will be involved
is when you move that end result
set that we have aggregates
or something that you created.
If you want to move
it back into GCP,
then egress would be there.
But otherwise, you don't have
to worry about any of that.
All that is managed service.
We take care of all that stuff.
AWS is available now, and
Azure will be coming soon
in coming quarters.
So let's switch gears now
and look at the second topic.
We covered BigQuery from
an analytics perspective.
Now let's go to our data
lake side of things.
If you think about Google Cloud,
some of the largest data lakes
are running on the top of GCP.
And customers like
Twitter and Pandora--
all of them run
large-scale clusters on us.
And the reason is
it's super fast.
It's secure.
It's managed.
And it's cost effective
for organizations.
And we do support
managed experience
around various different Apache
projects like Spark and Hadoop
and Scala and Presto and Druid.
And I just pick one, like enable
you to run Ranger, all of that.
And also, we have
managed Airflow,
which is available as Composer
service that is there.
Then I, today, wanted to
talk about a few key roadmap
items in this area.
One is enterprise notebooks.
Second is Dataproc
metastore, and then
analytics on Kubernetes.
Again, more details
another session.
We launched our Cloud AI
notebooks in recent past,
right?
It's available.
Organizations are using
it across the board.
You can have your
personal notebook.
You can create a
team notebook with
Kubernetes-backed environment.
But what we have launched now--
it's in beta-- that's available
is our Smart Analytics
framework.
And what that is, is we are
bringing on the big data
capabilities, big data services,
behind-the-scene Cloud AI
notebooks environment, and
enabling you to run this
on top of a Dataproc cluster.
So basically, large-scale Spark
jobs can now run on top of it.
You just go and
create a notebook
from Dataproc environment.
And then it's available.
And then you also have
the Beam notebook.
And it also connects with
BigQuery, Dataflow, Dataproc.
All of these engines
become accessible to you
from the same thing.
Really powerful,
really looking forward
to enabling these data
scientists across the globe
to leverage this new
environment that's available.
The next topic I
want to talk about
is managed Dataproc
metastore, or Hive metastore.
Lot of organizations
have told us managing
the Hive metastore is painful.
We should just have a
managed version of it.
That's exactly what we're doing.
It's going to be completely
integrated with our security
capability, monitoring
capability in Google Cloud.
It will support all the
major security capabilities
that organizations need.
Over time, we will
enable all of that stuff.
So that is there.
Then you will be able to
go ahead and scale out
over time and all of that.
So it's available
in beta this year.
And so I would highly
recommend using this.
If you're running any kind
of a Hadoop environment
on top of Hadoop or Spark
environment in Google Cloud,
you should use the
managed metastore now.
And finally, I'm super excited
about this transition from YARN
to Kubernetes in
the big data world.
And we're binding some of
it with our launch of Spark
on Kubernetes.
And we believe that this is the
best next step for open source
community to adopt Kubernetes.
And so right now, we have
Spark on Kubernetes available.
We are looking at other
options like Flink and Presto.
But this is a great way of
running Spark environment where
Kubernetes becomes the backbone
for management and all.
One of the other
things this enables
is for you to now run Spark
jobs on top of BigQuery.
Earlier, I talked about
how BigQuery enables
you to have the analytical
storage accessible
from Dataproc and Beam.
With this now, you can
have Spark on Kubernetes
connected to BigQuery.
You can run large-scale Spark ML
jobs or various different kinds
of aggregates that
you may want to run
outside of BigQuery SQL,
so great way of doing that.
With that, let me actually
switch gears and talk
about the next
topic that we have,
which is around building
more responsive businesses
with real-time
environment, right?
So we covered BigQuery,
analytical cloud data
warehousing.
And we covered data lakes.
Now let's talk about now
Dataflow and Pub/Sub.
If you look at real time,
it's becoming really critical.
There's a standard pattern.
In just large-scale events,
you want to transform them.
And you want to analyze
and solve them later.
And so the pattern
normally in GCP--
the way it works
is you use Pub/Sub
for large-scale connection.
You can always use Kafka.
Confluent has a good
managed service on that.
You can transform
and transformations.
Normally, Dataflow
is the best engine,
I think, across all clouds
for running large-scale stream
processing.
And then you can also use
Spark if you wanted do.
And then for analyzing
and storing later,
you can use Cloud ML.
You can use BigQuery.
You can use Bigtable.
There are a lot of
different options there.
In the roadmap side,
I wanted to highlight
a few of the key things here.
One was Pub/Sub Lite,
Dataflow SQL making
it easy to get started
with streaming pipelines,
observability and
manageability, and, of course,
streaming predictions.
Again, more details in
another session in 101.
If you think about a
collection of events,
Pub/Sub is an amazing
global service.
As I said, Spotify uses it.
Large-scale organizations
are using it.
But we've seen adoption of lot
of do-it-yourself messaging
platforms on GCP.
A lot of organizations
have said, hey,
we want a lower-cost option.
We want something to
get started in smaller
teams, departmental use cases.
And then Pub/Sub Lite
is exactly for that.
It's a zonal service.
It's super low cost so that
organizations can get started.
They don't have to manage
their infrastructure.
It's a fully managed, really
low price and low cost offering.
I would actually
challenge you to compare
your do-it-yourself costs
against Pub/Sub Lite.
And I think Pub/Sub
Lite will become
much more compelling for
you even in those scenarios.
It's a zonal service.
So keep that-- let
you know you should
have that in your failover
scenarios and stuff like that.
Think through what use
cases you're enabling.
And then it will integrate with
Dataflow and other services
like Cloud Functions and
all natively out of the box.
The other thing I want
to highlight today
is Dataflow SQL.
We want to make
building/streaming pipeline
super easy.
Dataflow SQL allows you
to write SQL statements
to create complex pipelines.
You use the same BigQuery
experience for writing SQL.
It's the same BigQuery UI.
And some of the innovation
that we've done in BigQuery--
UI with multi tabs and all--
I'm super excited
about that too.
But you can just
write a SQL statement
and create the whole pipeline.
And we'll take care of all
of the creation, management,
all of that after that.
The things that
it's available today
is with Pub/Sub as
well as BigQuery.
We're going to add Kafka.
We're going to add Bigtable and
Cloud SQL in addition to those.
And then we also were looking
at UDFs and enabling UDFs.
Creating pipelines--
making it easy is great.
But a lot of
organizations want us
to go ahead and make
manageability and operational
management of these
pipelines really easy.
So we just launched our
observability dashboards
early in the year.
Managed pipelines
is coming too, which
allows you to take any
pipeline, go dig deeper
into individual steps
of what happened
and what the
bottleneck was and how
do you resolve the bottleneck.
So a lot of that stuff is
getting better and better
with time.
Finally, two of the key
trends in Google Cloud
is streaming and
AI services, which
is machine learning and AI.
And we are bringing
both of them together
with Dataflow, who are enabling
various different integrations
with Cloud AI,
APIs, and services,
integration with
TensorFlow Extended.
Now you can build streaming
pipelines, which basically
span from collect
large amount of events,
go ahead and transform them,
do the prediction in real time,
and then go ahead and serve
it from a serving layer.
We're not just stopping
at just base integration.
We're going to have
temporalized solutions
like anomaly detection.
But you can take
it and customize it
for your industry,
your use case,
and then go ahead and use it.
We have seen anomaly detection
being used for fraud detection
in financial services
or e-commerce sites.
We have seen that in network,
anomaly detection in telecom,
and all of that.
So these standardized
patterns and templates
are going to help organization
to adopt it faster.
Finally, we are also going
to enable GPUs and TPUs
through Dataflow pipelines.
This has been one of the
most asked-for capabilities.
So you will have
that capability, too.
So we covered BigQuery,
the data warehousing.
We covered data lakes.
We covered streaming analytics.
Let's switch gears to enterprise
BI and data applications.
So Looker now is part of
the Google Cloud family.
It's a great data
platform that's available.
And basically, Looker is
based on this amazing semantic
modeling layer.
It allows you to define
your common understanding
of your metrics within
the organization.
And this is one of the
biggest pain points
for most of our customers.
They basically have
different-- like,
since service BI
enabled everybody
to define their own
dashboards, but also
everybody to have their own
definition of their metrics.
So with Looker, you basically
define your common metrics.
This allows
organizations to rally
behind the common understanding
of these key metrics.
It also has this BI capability
with great visualizations
and great tooling for your
dashboards and reports and all.
So that's always there.
Another thing it
allows you to do
is everything in
Looker is an API.
So you can build your own custom
applications and custom use
cases and workflows
on top of Looker.
Some of the organization
using Looker
are, like, you can't even
see anything in Looker there.
It's just an API,
headless BI platform
that you can go
ahead and do whatever
UIs you want on top of it.
And then we've seen a
lot of organizations
use embedded
Looker, where Looker
gets embedded into other
applications and all.
It works with more than 55
different kind of SQL dialects,
means different databases and
data warehouses in the world,
including BigQuery and some
of the other cloud providers.
Today, there's actually a
long list of capabilities
we are adding with Looker.
There is a great
session that will go
and deep dive into that.
But today, I want to highlight
the three key capabilities
that we're enabling--
Looker on GCP, integration
with the BI Engine,
and then instant exploration.
So first of all, making
Looker available in the Cloud
console in GCP is one of our
big priorities this year.
What that will enable you to
do is you can, with one click,
get access to Looker,
get started, and leverage
the product.
But one of the most
important things
is we are also focusing on all
the key security horizontals
that you all care about.
Like, you want CMEK,
and you want VPCSC.
All of those different
kind of horizontals,
they will come over time.
But that's part of
being a Google service,
where we're focused on that.
The second thing is
better integration
with BigQuery is, of course,
one of our priorities.
Now BigQuery plus Looker
is an amazing combination.
Like, there is unlimited
scale on one side
and then great visual
capabilities but common APIs
that you can use
semantic modeling layer.
It's really good story together.
And with BI Engine, our
in-memory caching layer,
you can now start bringing
these two together
and get subsecond latencies
on most of your dashboarding
and reporting use cases or
different visualizations
you want to go over.
Finally, in Looker, you do
have to start with a model,
define it in LookML.
And we wanted to make it
very easy for organizations
and analysts in organizations
to go from BigQuery
and start using the
power of Looker.
And basically what
you will be able to do
with this instant
exploration capability
is you can write a
query in BigQuery UI.
And with one click, you can get
into visualization with Looker.
You will be able to go ahead
and add calculated fields.
You can share those
visualizations with your peers
within the organization.
And then finally, when
you're ready to go
through this higher-level
capability with enterprise
capability with the governed
BI and have this modeling
layer that you
want to customize,
then you can go ahead
and upgrade for that.
But just starting
off and getting
started with Looker
with BigQuery
is going to become super simple.
With a few clicks, you will
be able to go through that.
We covered a lot of stuff today
across Cloud data warehousing,
data lakes, streaming analytics,
as well as enterprise BI
and data applications.
We have tons of
more stuff coming.
There are a lot of details that
we have across the portfolio.
In last few years, we've been
leaders in every report that's
come out from analysts.
Forrester-- that's
a good one where,
for 2020 Data Management
and Analytics Wave.
we were the leader.
Same thing with Gartner
reports that have come out.
And we're going to
continue focusing
on enhancing our products,
getting feedback from you,
making sure that we are working
on the right priorities.
There are also a lot
of other sessions
that the team is doing that
you can get more deep dive
across different
aspects of the products
and different
capabilities that we have.
We have 30-plus additional
sessions with customer use
cases, how customers
and organizations
are using the platforms.
I would highly recommend
viewing all of those.
And finally, thank you
for your time today.
Really appreciate
listening to our roadmap
for Smart Analyltics.
Thank you.